what I want to get you guys to think
about and with Excel open I'll give you
guys two or three minutes to do this
together
here's how many clans an analysis can
you do with a spreadsheet how many
different kinds of analysis if you
remember we went through a list of like
six or seven different kinds okay and
there were sort of broad calories I want
you to go dig into the digging other
venues go and have a look through all of
these things okay and see how many kinds
of analysis are there but if you just
think varieties I'll give you two
minutes to do that and then we'll come
back to it all right I think that's
enough time I think you've got most of
the main ideas let's start I've wrote me
right hand side the room
just give me one just give me one what's
one type of analysis you found can be
simple sorting thank you I'm very glad
this is the first one by the way because
sorting is kind of like the bread and
butter analysis of Excel okay of all
spreadsheets really you just want to get
things into order that's really really
helpful that's very meaningful but you
can know who's the top who's the middle
who's that all that kinda thing so
couple okay let's move it over gentleman
in the front you guys have one but it's
different you can what if analysis
you've got to be right with that one
because it easily has analysis in their
analysis okay yes yes this is a legit
phrase now by the way in case you are
coming member what it's about right it's
when you've got a certain set of values
that interact with each other that are
related okay and you want one to be a
certain date for instance you know how
much money you've got how much time
you've got how much interest you've got
and then using all of those you can
calculate how much am I going to earn on
a loan right well suppose you want to
target you know I want to get to $50,000
so then you say what if I have $50,000
what will happen to the rest of my
variables and you can adjust them okay
good let's go up the back and the middle
guys can give me one everyone
we're missing lots of obvious categories
so far so you shouldn't have search
difficulty I'm waiting waiting
hey Jack Jack can anyone okay so Jack
Jack Jack is not a valid method of
analysis on a spreadsheet I don't know
which menu for you found that in but I'm
gonna give it a thumbs down can you give
me one that's better really obvious ones
are easy still lady gentlemen
we're all waiting everyone on YouTube is
waiting say it again Kim what do you
mean by that
hmm do you explain how that's analysis
Shh
yeah good good okay
so the idea behind lookup is
particularly relevant when you've got
massive pools of data it's kind of like
search absolutely which is also an
important method of analysis
okay pass go collect $200 just barely
all right I heard on this side girls can
you give us one there I think we're
still missing the most obvious one
actually pumping sorting on this set
again can't locate calculations now
let's uh let's go after this as you guys
know there's calculations and then
there's calculations so what is some of
the specific kinds of calculations that
Excel could do which are helpful for
analysis yeah okay good so an average or
it mean okay I had another one I mean
standard deviation which is a measure of
central tendency but a measure of spread
okay um other ones well because they say
again okay yeah you can do the add stuff
up right okay Wow here we go really how
we gonna do every type of mathematical
okay all right
abs
okay um ghazal the left-hand side can
you give me one that's not on this list
at all you know that doesn't have to be
a calculation anything else
yep yeah okay yeah okay
we've got a pretty good setting up okay
but I think you're missing a huge one
now I think that even is similar to some
of the calculations okay yeah yeah okay
thank you
now look at is list like a look at the
list all of this could be done back when
I was still really done and all we had
was like text-based
spreadsheets okay or just running daus
it was really the colors are lawful
because there wasn't 16 million colors
there was just 16 colors if you're lucky
okay none of this has to do with any
other video so you're all missing you're
missing an entire time here look at all
these guys I would argue these are
possibly the most valuable for us in
terms of like basic analysis of what
kinds of meaning we can get out of
something right it's a graphical
representation so the question is is
graphing organizing yeah I'm gonna say
remember that the seven person right
they don't neatly sort of divide up okay
they're not they they sometimes overlap
okay a typical example who say data
compression right which is sort of like
organizing and analyzing and processing
and probably start retrieving all at
once right
I think graphing probably fits better
under analyzing if it's better there
because generally when we stop
organizing we mean file format like say
word versus PDF so their format in
different ways for different purposes
and remember organizing is always going
somewhere right whereas a graph might be
your end point I've done all of this
other stuff and I finished with my graph
the graph is not for something else the
graph is the point
um so you guys can read off all the
different kinds of graphs I should write
that down
graphical representation you've also got
not just graphical representation but
graphical interpretation
you guys remember and maybe you want to
just uh experiment with this in your
Excel spreadsheet I just want you to
down the up down a column put some
random values in maybe anything you like
okay um
okay now one of the cool things you can
do if you select all of the values that
you just put down and I think it's I
think it's in the herd yeah okay yet up
here conditional formatting can you see
that icon there should be quite large
okay I want you to select it you've got
all these different analysis options
they're all visual okay so for instance
the one that I tend to use quite a lot
you might have seen me use it in the
exam breakdowns and reviews color scales
you can map these values to a color
based on whether it's good or bad okay
so for instance if I pick this one okay
when we got right so the worst score is
here the deepest color of red okay and
the best score is here it's the deepest
color of green you've got everything
else in between
okay and in fact if you see if you sort
it you can see the rainbow effect right
because it's just cascade your course
and what's really great about this is
for instance if you take a value you can
adjust it and the colors will adjust
along with it right it's dynamic so for
instance that rank there right it's
still the same it's still the same okay
but now if I take some ones in between
and make you say 90 okay can you see it
it's interpreting the value for us
automatically okay